okay so what the reason why when
somebody calls somebody average that's
usually perceived to be an insult right
I think we hear it that way we give it
that way nobody's ever told somebody
that there's ever their average is like
a nice thing to say to somebody now we
can say that like oh well average is
most people are average kind of but also
not really right if you look at like an
average person like an average person
has 1.9 legs because some people are
missing legs but no human has 1.9 legs
we have two or one right when we look at
who we are as people there are some
things that we excel at and there are
some things that we don't do anything at
so I think that's why we never feel
average right because we're above
average hopefully at whatever our
competency is in So when you say that
somebody's average is always going to be
perceived as an insult so I'm sure that
uh Camilla or anybody else you guys all
had crazy degree you guys are all more
educated than I am right I'm sure that
on a whole you might be an average
person but you're not going to perceive
yourself that way because you push
yourself forward in some areas that make
you not average and hopefully you're
looking for other people to plug into
that those uh above average
I just want to say it's not about even
my degree you know it's not about my
Masters it's about what I've overcome
and achieved in this life that makes me
a Survivor and above average I have been
homeless on the street and I'm sitting
here today and not representing that my
struggle My Success makes me above
average and nobody can't tell me that
I'm not because if that's what I need to
tell myself to get up in the morning and
do my [__] that's what's gonna have to
happen okay
hold on
Bros
you disrespecting me so I've got a
reason don't talk to me like that bro
stop stop stop stop I just told you to
stop I just start I just told you to
stop talking guys I was gonna you a
chance but you can't you can't come on
Wow 30 30 seconds ago wow 30 seconds and
then you 30 seconds just can't stop
talking okay anyway I can't remember she
just threw me off I remember okay
um it was just so funny okay okay
oh wait wait wait wait wait hold on guys
guys guys guys no listen listen listen
listen guys guys
guys
the mics are off now guys guys guys guys
yo yo yo all right all right guys okay
okay all right thank you you're the
first rule of the podcast don't
interrupt the host yeah we're not gonna
tolerate that no more if that happens
you gotta go thank you
yeah are we all cool with that okay all
right cool thank you I know and no
disrespectful stuff either thank you
okay wait wait oh come on okay no no no
no no stop okay thank you
um we're gonna go on to the next
question all right all right so I'm
gonna need okay
this might be your platform but respect
okay okay goodbye go go go okay because
[Music]
don't call me bro I don't know
I'm just embarrassing yourself
I know you know something right do you
know something like excuse me excuse me
excuse me what's your name hello young
lady what's your name T do you know what
I'm gonna do for the first time ever I'm
gonna [__] follow you
see you later
okay okay look at look at look at look
at your your issue your issue stop
you're doing it again okay oh my God
oh my God
yeah
I'll smoke you myself
why
yeah damn right well teach you a lesson
next time you're [__] talking to your
mother name
[Music]
let's go
you need something
you you keep over to us get get get out
get out get out get out get out
how many bodies oh my God get out get
out
get
the [__] out of my apartment get out oh
my God
oh my god oh oh my God
okay hold on can I just for my own
safety who are we allowed to call for
out here and who are we not allowed to
call bro I just want to know
get the [__] out lock the door blessing
go lock the other side too blessing lock
the [__]
yo the only reason was because she kept
interrupting me Jesus Christ
okay I don't oh my God
what can you go check just go go double
check go
no but okay that's fair enough
that has never had I've never had anyone
lock off or kicked out I think best as
we move on quick coffee goodbye okay
yeah but she's saying I was
disrespectful to how
[Laughter]
the only reason I was gonna let her talk
is the crazy thing but she kept
interrupting me and I was just like if
you're gonna keep interrupting me you
have to go like I don't
is the same one in this podcast
okay um I can't believe Auntie Jenny was
worse than me just saying okay hold on
we shouldn't shut down anybody I'm not
trying to be fair okay I didn't think
anyone was that crazy until she started
yeah okay my next question
I actually didn't think it was that bad
but I guess I just want to know why
she's so mad that cool or broke when I
call everyone bro
it's just a respect thing it's like your
elders like I just would never I don't
know yeah yeah it's just like I just
wouldn't call people that but I don't
think
I don't think you meant it like that no
I I think they were already upset and
then him saying bro was just like a
Timmy but they were cool and they were
calling each other
it doesn't matter
yeah and I think it's because you kept
antagonizing the situation she was like
don't call me Brian you're like all
right bro
yeah
when I'm speaking like it's just my
vernacular that's just how I speak in it
like so I'm even thinking like oh yeah
I'm trying to push her buttons like all
my thing was is that let me say
something because at this point I've
said the least out of everybody do you
get what I'm saying so I was just trying
I said the most yeah
but she wasn't the one talking at that
moment at that moment as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible